spend time in a city like New York and
you start to notice something there are
a ton of sleepies natural stores around
here 32 in Manhattan alone to be exact
we're not talking about daily
conveniences like a coffee shop bank or
a drugstore the average American only
buys a new mattress every 10 years or so
by comparison Best Buy sells electronics
which people are always buying you know
the best buys there are in Manhattan
so why are there so many sleepers well
the answer is actually more complicated
than you might think
some of what's going on here is business
101 want to grow open more stores human
psychology also plays a role here too we
tend to think things will get better not
worse and that natural optimism can make
us think of expanding our business
unless or until circumstances dictate
otherwise retail can also be marketing
every storefront is also a billboard and
even if a particular store isn't making
a lot of money it may still be worth it
if it reinforces in the mind of the
customer that you are the place to go by
in this case mattresses then there's the
fun world of commercial real estate
sometimes a landlord will package
multiple properties together if you want
that super prime location like this one
here on Fifth Avenue you might also have
to pick up another less than awesome
location to seal the deal
by the way we did approach sleepies for
comment and they did decline however a
group of commercial real-estate
professionals industry analysts and
Business School professors with a
surprising amount of knowledge about the
mattress industry were willing to talk
so what sets sleepies apart from other
retailers one thing we learned about the
mattress game the profit margins are
awesome up to 50 percent per mattress
with numbers like that you don't have to
move a lot of them to have a really good
day not only are the margins terrific
but the risk to sleep ease is actually
quite minimal that's because they're not
tying up a lot of their cash and
inventory stored in warehouses in fact
sleepies often only pays a manufacturer
for its back when you are i by one of
their mattresses you also don't need an
absolutely perfect location nobody's
really window shopping here I mean it's
not like you roll up in front of us
sleepies and suddenly say oh my god I
get one of those sealy posturepedics
sleepies isn't so much selling
mattresses as people are buying them
because of that they can choose less
than desirable locations like second
floors which can run for up to 50
percent less than a store that's on the
street and while there may be new online
competitors like Casper and sattva most
people are still only comfortable buying
a mattress after they've lied on one
under the watchful gaze of a salesperson
it's never not awkward but for the time
being at least selling a mattress is
still internet proof